Ben would you like to hit some headlines with us?
I would want nothing more than to hit some headlines.
(audience applauds)
Come on.
Thank you.
Take it away then.
First up, a story from Thrillist,
they are reporting that Spice Fusion,
a tasty little spot in Kent, England,
has a new promo offer, exclamation point.
(Drew laughs)
There is a tiny phone jail provided at every table.
And if everyone in your party
locks up their phone at dinner, you get 20% off,
and that's 20% off apps, entree's, drinks,
the whole shebang, everything.
They're calling it "The Dinner Is Better
When We Eat Together Promotion.
I love this.
(audience applauds)
Yeah?
I, I-
Yeah, you'd like in?
You want in?
I love this.
(Ross laughing)
I love this so much.
The idea of being at dinner and not,
when we're all on our phones
I feel like we don't get to connect and all that stuff,
so I love the idea of putting our phones
in a little thing and talking.
And to get 20% off?
Oh my goodness.
Two things I love.
(audience laughs)
So it's like, I'm into this.
Would you do it?
So I went to a thing recently.
Should I say what it was?
Yes.
Okay, it was-
We'll bleep it out in post,
we'll bleep it out in post.
It was a Madonna event and it was very intimate and small.
And of course, I was like, let's...
Okay, so you get it there and they lock your phone up,
in a thing and they don't give it to you.
They're like, "No, put it in
and we'll give it to you when you leave."
And you're like, "Okay."
Great!
Good!
Yes, thank you!
I mean, how many times have you done that?
When you're at dinner with someone
and you're like "Oh my God, I'm putting my phone down.
I'm sorry."
And then 30 seconds later,
you're like, "But I just wanna check Insta."
I do it all the time,
and I feel like this would give me major anxiety.
This is the only way you could get me to skip dessert.
If you had to, like,
you can have it when the meal's over, I'd rush through.
But I love the sentiment of this, you know?
We're all sitting down,
we should be looking each other in the eye,
we should be communicating,
we should be forgetting about the rest of the world.
So I love it, in theory,
in practice, it gives me anxiety.
Can I see a show of hands of who,
you know, and remember, we get a discount here,
who would be game for this?
Raise of hands.
This is amazing.
I dunno, maybe,
what if people started doing this even at home?
You know, as a sort of incentive,-
Yes, yes.
Like at home,
Phones down.
Yeah.
I love a phones down.
(audience applauds and cheers)
All right.
Well, next up, we got news on the science of laughter.
This is interesting.
Oh!
The BBC reports, a new study proves
that laughter from a studio audience
or even canned laugh tracks
can actually make jokes funnier.
This is something that sitcoms have known for years.
And now, a study played some real,
real groaner dad jokes for their subjects.
And when they paired it with laughs,
the jokes actually rated as funnier.
So guess what?
I have some of those jokes right here.
Yeah!
I love a Dad joke.
Do we have a laugh track?
We have a laugh track.
Now these are not good jokes, you understand?
But they they're gonna be funny, 'cause listen, ready?
How about this?
Why can't you give Elsa a balloon?
'Cause she'll let it go.
'Cause she'll just let it go.
(laugh track chortling)
(audience laughs)
Sorry, that's a kids joke.
I know that one.
Well listen, did you hear the laugh track?
(laugh track chortling)
I, I, this,
Psychologically speaking,
this feels understandable.
Totally.
How a cacophony of laughter could envelop you
and kind of pick you up and get you swept up in it.
Well it's like when you watch sitcoms.
Remember "Cheers" always said,
"Cheers is taped in front of a live studio audience"
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right?
And the laughter at home helps sell the jokes.
(laugh track chortling)
and Ben, when you're on stage-
Thank you.
(Drew laughs)
Oh, it made me laugh.
I like that.
Yeah, it made you laugh.
Oh my God.
I find it so spooky.
I hated that.
That's not scary to anybody else?
'Cause it's fake?
It sounds like people from the sixties trapped in a room
and being forced to laugh.
(audience laughs)
Play it one more, wait, play it.
Well, I'm gonna say a dramatic,
just listen how it's all so spooky.
Actually, I'm sorry, but your, um,
your father is in the hospital.
(laugh track chortling)
That's terrifying.
(audience laughs)
I hate that, don't you wanna let,
listen how, live, you can respond to these humans laughing.
Yeah, it's not good.
It's funny, it works if you say a punchline,
but if you say like, "I have a weird rash".
(laugh track chortling)
Okay.
Okay, all right
(Drew laughs)
See? That's funny.
You're right, if something's on the cusp-
Your dad in the hospital.
I laughed, 'cause I always laugh at naughty things,
or when you're not supposed to laugh.
I feel like I have my own personal nightmare laugh track
that I can't control.
And it's coming out.
It's like, if I am somewhere
where I'm not supposed to laugh,
I'm constantly holding that laugh track inside.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Or if somebody tells me horrible news,
I'm like, "Oh God!"
It's uncomfortable,
and the first thing I wanna do is laugh
'cause it's the wrong response.
Yes.
Yeah.
So I just, I have someone inside of me
with a pitch fork,
Mm-hm.
You know, just gunning for me to laugh.
I relate to that laugh track.
I would really like to have a button
that controls that laugh track.
So if I'm ever out here one day and a joke doesn't go over,
I can just be like...
(laugh track chortling)
There you go.
(bright theme music)